2020 was my year of being like
letting everything go and just like no
fear 2020 was sophia rich's year of
letting go
and it looks like 2021 is her year of
finding new love
a source tells et that she's dating
music executive
elliot grange and that they are happy
together and having fun
the source also says they've been
friends for years
it's very nice for sophia to date
someone who her family approves of
and likes great things are happening and
i'm really excited about it
if you're wondering who elliott is he's
the son of universal music group
chairman
lucian grange he's also the ceo of his
own company
10k projects
sophia's new romance comes after her
famous 2020 split from scott disick
so i'm going to finland for spring break
let me tell you don't rain and i just
um said to scotland do you want to
invite sophia
they don't make me feel like i'm left
out though which is nice
that's something or else i wouldn't like
go or invite her
to come after that episode sophia told
et why she had
no plans to return to keeping up with
the kardashians
are we going to see more of you next
season on that show no more
um no why not well because
i want i want to get into acting are you
auditioning right now are you reading
scripts what can you
tell us the rules i'm reading right now
are very like close to
i feel like are kind of similar to me
so they're easy for me to play and i i
really
really enjoy it so i think i've been
enjoying these roles they're similar to
me
meanwhile scott is going strong with
amelia hamlin
they started dating in late 2020
though if it was up to his other ex
kourtney kardashian's fam
they'd still be together do we think
they're like hooking up again i just
want them to try
i mean i think we've been through so
much in so many things and to hear her
be proud of me means you know a ton to
me the court has also moved on from
scott
according to a source she's getting more
serious with blink 182's
travis parker the couple recently
traveled to palm springs and utah
together with their kids
where they had a little fun with this
tik tok vid
i'm passing the phone to my boyfriend
i'm passing the phone to someone with a
tampon in his nose
[Music]
you